mamadou duff and his friend ibrahima are
on a school visit to the museum of black
civilization
to see the work of pablo picasso the guy
gives an impassioned explanation on why
picasso belongs to african art
ibrahima finds it all boring
but mamadou sees in picasso's brush
strokes something familiar and so he
stays on
did the mask inspire picasso or picasso
inspire the mask
he wonders before realizing the answer
lies in front of him i know the mask
inspired picasso
these are two masterpieces look at the
form of the face and nose they are so
similar the artist who did this one is
famous the other one has been forgotten
but is much older
in 1907 french painter ari matisse took
his friend picasso to a colonial
exhibition in paris where african
artifacts and people from the continent
were put on display in what were
referred to as human zoos the exhibition
radically changed the way picasso
painted and sculpted
the aim of the exhibition is to show the
link between picasso and african art
on this side is a bronze sculpture from
picasso using mixed materials and behind
is a shot of a traditional horse with a
human face a typical animist african
mask
picasso never traveled to africa but his
work has the exhibition is a copy of one
that took place 50 years ago but the
public's perception of the artists has
since changed just outside the museum
the contemporary art gallery lumenege is
challenging picasso's work
this piece by a french senegalese artist
quotes pablo picasso it says black art
don't know what it is now some believe
that this is an attempt by pablo picasso
to distance himself from what inspired
him the
traditional african art others believe
that the artist was making a statement
saying there's no such thing as black
art it's just art
either way in this exhibition young
african artists are reinterpreting pablo
picasso's work making it their own
not picasso's faint painting guernica
but perhaps as powerful the work of an
ivorian artist and this painting is an
answer to picasso's work de
explained to young senegalese painter
artist sandra seger
my painting seeks to confront the
problems that i have with picasso like
the way women are portrayed and how
african objects when used by a man in
the west are seen as genius
what i see in picasso are the objects
and masks of my culture that were robbed
exposed but devoid of meaning
a genius or a thief
a new generation of african artists are
challenging the status quo
for a young public
eager to break from the past and see
picasso in the new light
nicholas hawk al-jazeera dakar